Okay.
So, um,
You were talking about being a nerd.
I like how she reminded you of that. Maybe not a tape.
Oh, I'll move her, I'll
Move her here because I want to have that thing in there.
Um, yeah. You know that, that got captured on the recording.
That kind started off. Yeah, it did.
Uh, that'll be the first thing people hear about tonight.
So, and they won't
Believe it.
Okay. But one of my hobbies was making model airplanes.
And, uh, I just loved to do that.
And I'd make these mostly World War II fighting
planes, and once I made them, I would,
I would sometimes paint 'em
and hang them on the ceiling from in my bedroom.
Fortunately, my older brother put up with that.
He didn't deny me that opportunity
and had a lot of fun doing that.
And, uh, that was all kind of capped off
after, um, we had our son
and, uh, he, he joined our family.
And when he got to be about the same age
that I started making models, I,
I introduced him to making it.
And he seemed to like that. And we decided
to make a B 24 bomber together,
because that was the plane that my dad helped build
during World ii.
And, uh, so we made this B 24 bomber,
and we really took our time, made it really look good,
and painted it, and then we presented it to my father.
Mm-Hmm. And, uh,
he was kind of an emotional guy.
He just didn't have permission to share emotions,
but he, he got tears in his eyes.
It really meant a lot to him.
And my mom gave it back to us when he died.
So my son has that now.
So, what was your hobby that brought you joy?
Share that with your spouse.
And this is, we're actually doing a bible verse
about relating, and it's Romans 1215.
It says, rejoice with those who rejoice. Mm-Hmm.
We're commanded to do that. Would you all agree with me?
We don't do much enough of that. Yeah.
We're not talking about worship.
I think we do a good job in, at least in this church
of worshiping, but I'm talking about just rejoicing
with one another, making much of fun,
happy, good things.
So take turns sharing, rejoice with each other.
If somebody jumps up
and down, we're not gonna throw you outta here.
It's okay. But go right ahead.
I should try to help me
Remember that. 'cause once I get
going, I just,
the back.
You try to,
We'll take another minute or so and then I'll wrap.
Okay.
Did you build any models from 12 o'clock High?
Remember the show 12 o'clock High?
No. I, I remember the title of
that movie, but I don't remember
Seeing the movie.
It was a World
War II Yeah. TV
show and it probably from planes coming from the
Bombers or fire.
Yeah. Yeah. I tell you, I've read a lot of books
that are from that era and, uh, watch a lot of movies.
But that one, if I saw it,
I probably saw it way back there, so.
Okay.
All right. So emotionality,
how did your family handle
emotions, Rosa?
I couldn't miss that. You had a recall there of some sort,
but, uh, I'm not asking you to necessarily go here.
It's just, you know, one of those things, when you think
Italian family, welcome
to the first thing that comes to mind.
Yeah. It's expression,
Fireworks and expression.
And
Very animated people. Yeah.
They're Still pretty animated. Yeah.
They're still very animated.
So it did not teach you to stuff your emotions, right?
How do you know? No, not
Really. No, I wouldn't
likely do that.
That's just mainly explosive, which is just as bad.
Well, and it can be hard
to get in a wording edgewise sometimes when the culture
is, is more like that.
Um, anybody else in here with a German ancestry?
Yeah. Uh, well, that didn't mean
that nobody got to show emotions,
but it meant it was restricted to a certain one.
Mama, mama, Mama istic.
But, um, the rest of us were not expressing as much.
So anyway, that was part of our background.
So, um, I remembered, uh,
a time the other night, this might have been the thing
that I was trying to think of.
We were Friday night at a meeting with the louder backs
that if you were at the workshop, you remember them.
And, uh, they have a ministry that's a nonprofit,
and we were at a meeting of the board
and, um, we, we were celebrating
the history of where they've come from, the things
that they've had, the adversities they've had to go through,
and just the amazing way that God was working to
move them forward in their ministry in spite
of things like she shared about having cancer a second time.
And yet God's kind of unfolding some new chapters for them
and how they're gonna do this thing.
And, uh, so that was a,
that's a real rejoicing experience like that.
And I may have shared, I don't remember
for sure about when I was 23
and I had my 23rd birthday in New York City
after moving there a week before.
And I was working
with some people in a nonprofit organization,
and I knew some of them
and didn't know some of the others yet.
But they took me out
to a restaurant in Greenwich Village, a Greek restaurant.
And, and they're not too far from Italy, right?
Greece and Italy. Actually, I had actually, uh,
worked in a Greek restaurant.
Okay. So I, I understand there's a major restaurant.
So here I am, new kid on the block,
they're throwing a birthday party for me at this restaurant.
And it's a lively atmosphere, great food,
uh, someone singing with a string instrument.
And, uh, of course the only song we knew was,
or of the Greek, I think.
But, but it was a great time.
And that was the first time I remember since I was about
five or six years old being celebrated in any way, shape
or fashion that looked like that.
And I just remember how deeply it touched me.
But these people who barely knew me, were making much
of, it's your birthday, let's celebrate that.
Well, I don't think Jesus had a hard time celebrating
or having fun like
that based on some references in scripture.
Um, so I mentioned earlier, we don't celebrate enough
or rejoice enough that I would also say, I'm not sure we do
actually do enough with the Bible.
See, we don't do enough.
If all we do is obtain the cognitive information in our
brain and memorize it, that's still not enough.
We have to experience it.
So when it says rejoice with those rejoice,
it really means rejoice.
It really means experience something between you
that is actually positive, reflecting to positive.
And don't miss that scientists are just
now figuring all that out.
Um, tonight though,
we're gonna work primarily on the other half of that verse,
the mourn with those who mourn or weep with those who weep,
because that's where we oftentimes have not experienced
what we need to experience when we're the ones that are sad,
or we're the ones that are grieving
or have experienced a loss or disappointment.
And a lot of people try very hard to respond to someone
who has experienced a loss or sadness,
but they haven't been trained.
And I'm not talking about clinical training.
I'm just, no one has really shown them what really helps
a person when they are, when their heart is sad or broken.
Okay. So we're gonna look at
what does the Bible teach about that?
Um, I want to pass out, um,
Another handout.
There's one, There's enough
for one per couple on this one.
Thank you.
This is what
We call the pain and potential chart.
Did they get one? Yeah, it's going around. Okay.
Pain and potential chart.
It's referring to the relational needs,
but there's a, there's a real strong emotional part of this.
But if you just glance at this
and look at the top half of it, it's basically saying
that when a person's relational needs are being met
effectively in their relationships, it tends
to influence them to have healthy thoughts about themselves.
It tends to evoke positive emotions.
When your needs are met, you feel loved, you feel cared for,
you feel attended to, you might feel supported.
But those are positive feelings
and it that will motivate, not force,
but motivate productive behaviors.
So when a person's fitting loved, they typically
are grateful for that
unless they've learned somehow to dismiss
what was done for them.
And then that leads them into more potential for having
positive long-term outcomes.
But if the needs are not met, especially if
that's happening when the person is a child
and incapable of controlling their environment.
So if those needs are not being met,
it can leave them thinking negative thoughts about
themselves, about life, about, uh, others.
Uh, it can definitely stir up a lot of emotional, uh,
painful emotional feelings.
And if those emotions are not cared for
or healed, they accumulate.
Now, the way they accumulate is not like you're full
of negative emotions and, and you never get out of that.
It's like they store up in your brain, in, in your memories.
It's not like you're feeling them all the time.
It's when something reminds you of one of those painful me,
uh, feelings that you had earlier in life.
It's as if it compounds your current feelings.
So, for example,
Um, I have shared
that one thing I got a lot of from a mother who truly loved,
loved her children and loved me,
but, uh, I got a lot of criticism from her and no praise.
So it's a heavy imbalance of that's not right.
Do it, do it again. Uh, why do you miss
that one on the test when the, the grade was still good?
So I got a lot of that, that was really part
of my normal weekend, week out experience of life.
Uh, I would never say she was fully abusive.
It was just heavy on criticism,
very lacking on praise.
And that definitely influenced me.
Um, so when I get married and my bride
after a four month courtship,
during which I don't remember her
criticizing me a single time,
and she seemed heavy on approval
and praise, when she starts experiencing some
disappointment in my way of treating her, guess what?
Little frown start to show up on her face.
Little comments start to leak out,
and I start to have a meltdown with a little comment.
A $500 reaction to a 50 cent comment. Mm-Hmm mm-Hmm.
Now the question is, why did I blow up?
I'm not even a, I'm not Italian. I can't help it.
Not what Italian.
Oh, so why did I blow up?
And I'm gonna say in a very simple way of,
of something that's really complex in the brain,
but um, my brain just said, this
critical minor comment
is close enough to the negative words said
to you frequently that left you feeling small all the time.
That we are gonna have a meltdown internally,
even if you don't express it externally.
It's like, we're just going to add all
of those previous memories on top
of this one in milliseconds.
So you can't even tell that's what's going on.
Now, if you want to know anything more about this,
you can read about the amygdala and amygdala hijacks
and fight or flight
or freeze mechanisms that the brain is designed to have
to help protect you.
They're actually designed by a good God who knows
that you might need that.
But the problem is when the $500
comments are not being made, it's a 50 cent comment
that could be fairly easily worked through
if you didn't already have that predisposition.
So the amygdala hijack just crams it all together.
You have immediate flooding of your body and brain.
Your brain floods your body with adrenaline.
The next thing you know, you're flying outta
here or you're attacking.
But we don't want that to be
what typifies our relationships.
Okay? So good news is there's healing for that.
Second thing is, that's what's kind of depicted on here,
is if you've gone through a whole lot
of times when needs weren't met,
you may have an accumulation of memories
that may benefit from going back
and saying, I remember a time when
my brother moved away,
or I remember a time when my best friend moved away
and share that with Joyce
and her now know how to comfort me for that.
'cause we weren't trained to do that. Okay?
So that's the pain and potential, how that ties together
and motivates behavior, including, uh,
meltdowns, things like that.
So the emotional cup is the framework
that David Ferguson developed for trying to explain
how is your brain designed to work
and what happens with your emotions.
So we draw this picture of a cup,
and again, I know this won't be the first time for some
of you, but I want, this is so important to understanding
what's going on when I start to experience emotion.
So if this is a portion of my brain
or different pieces that I'm just saying, it's like a cup.
It's holding the emotion in a sense.
And when a negative life event occurs, it's going
to stir up some kind of emotion in me,
but it won't be joy if it's a negative life event.
It won't be happiness, it won't be, uh, I'm feeling blessed.
No, it's gonna feel painful.
And a lot of that will end up being a form of hurt,
sadness, sorrow, disappointment, rejection, betrayal.
Those are all vulnerable emotions
that are hurtful in some way.
And a lot of life events are like that. Okay?
My basketball team lost yesterday.
That's a very trivial example,
but it left me frustrated and hurt.
Frustrated goes up here. This is anger.
And that includes everything from just being mildly
irritated or annoyed
or frustrated to rageful, feeling rage,
feeling deep hostility in my heart.
Uh, then there's the category of fear,
which includes anxiety.
Even worry, we would tend to think in these terms,
fear where in that case, I'm anticipating
that something bad might happen,
but I'm probably remembering things that were similar
that happened already, but now I'm projecting.
Well, that's probably gonna happen too. Okay?
I've been rejected so often when I got up
to go ask Joyce if she wanted to play tennis in
that restaurant, there was a little fear at
work in me, okay?
Because I had not always had people say, of course,
I would see.
So my brain remembering past hurt
can actually use that to feed into my fear.
We would also say that underneath all anger is hurt.
If you see an angry person, chances are
they also are experiencing some hurt,
but the anger has sort of dominated.
That's what they'll be able to tell you they're feeling.
Unless you say, well, what else are you feeling?
I can see you're angry. Thank you
for telling me, but what else are you feeling?
And oftentimes they'll say, well, disrespected, I say, well,
that's not apol, that's not a strong emotion.
That's a, I mean, it's an important emotion,
but that's a vulnerable emotion.
Disrespected, I feel cheated.
Well, that's a vulnerable emotion,
but that might lead them to feel angry.
Okay? It may happen in millisecond.
Then another type
of emotion is guilt different than the first three.
And it's tied to your behavior.
Either something that you have done
or failed to do that violates your conscience
or your sense of God's principles.
Um, finally, condemnation.
These would be feelings that are not about your behavior,
but your sense of identity.
If I were to ask you today,
what is your identity from a
born again Christian perspective, what's your identity?
I probably ought to put Carrie on the spot here,
but she just took a drink of something.
Yes. What what's your identity?
Um, who are you from a Christian perspective,
I'm a child of God.
I'm a child of God, thank you. That that'll do.
There's other ways to answer that question,
but yeah, I'm a beloved child of God, right?
Even though I trust you're not yet perfect,
but you're still, your identity is not
what you do, who you are.
Okay? So feelings of condemnation tied
to a sense that I'm not enough,
or that if you really knew me,
you wouldn't think highly of me either.
It's a sense of who you are,
but it may not be consistent with you're a child
of God, a beloved child of God.
And even though the Holy Spirit still may be working
with you on certain behaviors,
that doesn't change who you are.
Okay? So what happens is, as we go through the life,
if these are not being emptied out of us, instead
of suppressed or held onto automatically, then
they're going to build up
and they're gonna keep potentially
driving symptoms.
Some of these symptoms are physical.
This, by the way, is on page 77 in your book
if you want to see the diagram.
Physical, behavioral,
uh, some involves, uh, escapes into things
that make us feel temporarily better, including alcohol,
drugs, porn, various kinds of escapes, even some
that don't sound so bad, like pleasure seeking, even in ways
that are not considered immoral.
Okay? I could be addicted to video games that are not in
and of themselves, bad images or stuff like that,
but I could be addicted to them where
they're starting to control my life.
Those are escapes and can become addictions.
There's things like difficulty sleeping, difficulty
with eating disorders.
Uh, there are people who just don't really feel much at all
because they've kind of numbed out.
And a lot of these are actually kind
of self preservation things,
but some of them go beyond that.
But the basic thing is these are often driven
by unresolved emotions within us,
or they're kept alive by those.
And when we're talking about counseling, we tend to not,
we hope we don't have to spend a lot of time trying
to manage or intervene up here.
We want to go right to this
and help people minister, help minister to
that pain and bring healing to it.
Because if you do bring healing to this pain
or resolve these emotions, well guess what happens
to the, the symptoms
Go away. Hmm? Go
Away. They go away.
Now,
some things are more difficult than others to deal with,
but that's the principle and the potential.
So the antidotes for these
Are medicines.
Joyce likes to call 'em medicine, okay?
That's one of her words that she really likes.
The antidotes for her is comfort, meaning Romans 12,
15, second part, weep with those who weep.
Now, that's kind of illogical to think that
one person weeping
with another person makes the first person feel better.
That's exactly what we're gonna show you in Matthew five,
four, that there is a connection between when one
of you is hurting, hurt with them,
and when you do, it helps heal the hurt.
It doesn't leave them alone with it.
And we've already been told it's not good to be alone.
So, um, that's the antidote for hurt.
Uh, anger has to be released
through a process of forgiveness.
But basically the idea here is if this is angering me, I am
actually letting it go, even though my flesh doesn't want
to, I wanna hang on to it, man.
I'm, I want to get even with that person
or take vengeance on that person,
or, uh, I'm afraid they'll come back
and I need to be angry when they come back.
So I can defend myself, all kinds
of reasons why I might want to hang onto that.
But Bible actually says, Bruce,
unless you want to go around being an angry person the rest
of your life, or having your heart kind of loaded down with
that, let's let go of that.
And that doesn't mean you have
to trust the person who hurts you.
That doesn't mean you have to lay down
and let them take advantage of you in one way or another.
You may have to have some boundaries with
that person out of love.
Yeah,
Fear and anxiety has to be, uh, displaced.
I think I'll write down here, released anger is released,
fear is displaced by
God's perfect love, reassuring love.
And oftentimes what that looks like is not fixing someone's
issue that causes them fear, like a,
a serious medical diagnosis, but walking alongside of them
and letting them have freedom to talk about it
and just saying, you know, if I could,
I'd fix it, that I can't.
But what I can do is I can be with you.
Guilt is confession
where I agree with my guilt,
but it is possible that you are blaming yourself for stuff
that God doesn't call guilt.
Like sometimes people have been led that
because somebody else got upset due to something they said
that they're, that they were wrong to say it.
And sometimes it's possible they didn't say anything wrong,
but the other person filtered it through a lens
that was inaccurate and got angry.
And I would say, well, we ought to have compassion for 'em,
but I don't think it's gonna help for me to confess
that I said something inappropriate if I didn't.
Does that make sense? That's the in
condemnation needs, the truth.
That's based on If you're a believer.
The word says that there is now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
So if I'm feeling condemnation, it's not coming from God,
it's coming from tapes or memories
or other people's accusations.
And I could be truly innocent,
but feeling condemnation,
and that's a residue from the past.
So tonight, we just want to focus on this one
by covering this verse.
Matthew five, four says, blessed
are they who mourn or they shall be comforting.
Now, if we had an extra half hour,
I would actually lead you all to do this in the room
with music playing to kind
of cover your conversations, okay?
Just to try to make it a little bit more private.
But instead, I'm just gonna say,
if you haven't done this one this week,
try doing it tonight before you go to bed.
It, it may only take you 15 minutes for the two of you
to share that, or it could take longer,
and that's great if it does.
But, um, this
word blessed literally means happier.
Happier are they who mourn,
which essentially means they feel sad
or they're grieving or they're hurt.
So this verse is saying, happier are they who feel sad?
Well, if you stopped right
there, it wouldn't make any sense.
It'd be an oxymoron.
But it's because they are comforted,
which means to feel sad for someone
or to feel compassion for them.
It's a movement in my heart that's not rational.
It's relation, it's emotional, such
that if I see somebody who's hurting and I,
and my heart doesn't go to, well,
you probably brought it on yourself,
you know, or things like that.
But I just simply go to compassion.
Like, like the Samaritan
who sees the winded traveler on the side of, of the road,
it says, his heart was moved with compassion
and that's what motivated him to actually go and help.
So if I'm feeling compassion for,
and with this one who's mourning,
this is the promise that comes out of that.
Now, the word most people use when they share something
with you and you comfort them, you just say,
I can see that you're hurting,
and I want you to know I care.
Tell me what, what, what happened to you?
And when they tell you and you find that you are continuing
to feel sorrow, sadness, compassion
for them, And sometimes you don't even have to use words.
They can see it in your eyes,
they can hear it in your tone of voice.
But if in doubt, just say, I want you to know I care.
I want you to know I care that that happened to you.
And the word they will often use is that as you were doing
that, I was feeling a measure
of relief from the sadness.
And that's totally different than suppressing sadness.
But that really means,
and this has been proven scientifically,
is there are new neuropathways being formed in your brain
when that process is taking place.
Different areas are lighting up, which is saying
that hurtful experience has now been paired up
with a healing experience where someone cared.
You'll find in the scripture that Jesus' emotions
that are most often mentioned is that he felt
or was moved with compassion,
like when Lazarus died.
And he comes and sees Mary and Martha Lazarus sisters
and says he was moved deeply within his, uh,
spirit with compassion.
And that's where it says Jesus wet.
Who is he crying for? He was crying for them.
And when you think about what he could have said,
because if he just said, now ladies,
just hold on a few minutes
because I'm gonna do something
that you're ne you've never seen before,
and yet you met them where were mm-Hmm.
So my encouragement is your homework,
Uh, would be to, and,
and if you've already done an exercise like
this, you probably have more.
We're actually saying if in your brain you've got a whole
lot of memories that have sadness or disappointment
or hurt tied to them even,
and right now I'm talking about ones
that don't involve your spouse, we're talking about other
hurts, then it would be good if every single one
of them was touched upon.
But I think what you'll find is when some are touched upon,
it's as if it's healing more than just that one.
But we're just saying that's God's way of healing it. Okay?
And it's not good to be alone with a bunch of dots.
A bunch of unhealed hurts. Okay?
So one thing we have found is we just periodically will
invite each other, you know, is there something else
that's come up in your thinking recently about other hurts?
And, uh, before we finish the class,
we'll also talk specifically about how do you now care
for the hurts that you've caused each other?
That's real important to deal with. Okay?
Questions or thoughts about that?
Do you hear people say, uh,
this is me just asking.
Mm-Hmm. So you hear the phrase that if someone's hurting,
uh, if you share it with someone, it's half.
I don't believe I actually understood that,
That it cuts it in half.
Yeah, it Cuts the pain head.
Do you, I mean, that's really not, yeah.
Do you believe in that at all?
I mean, it just, it's like they share your,
they carry your burden that you have your burden.
Yeah. Do you believe that any of
that really makes sense? I'm asking,
Well, actually, rose, actually I do,
but I think it's almost a different way of trying to say,
say the same thing, what that verse says,
blessed or happier.
But if they say, well, you've cut your pain in half,
well there's two of you and you're sharing it.
So I think that's probably where that saying comes from.
So I would not, uh, say that's technically right,
but it carries the same basic idea that
we can have tremendous impact on people we don't even know.
If we listen to their story, see that there's something
that's hurting them or has hurt them,
and we express empathy
and compassion, empathy can be, I can see
that you're hurting, or I can see
that was really hard for you.
Compassion is, and I want you to know I care that you had
to go through that or that you did go through that.
And those two statements spoken honestly
carry the benefit
of comforting that person.
Now, what we typically do
sometimes if we're the person who's mourning we might tell
these things to ourself, is we respond with,
uh, facts, logic,
Rationale, saying things like, well, you know,
that happened 30 years ago.
I should be over that by now happened a long time ago.
Well, that part might be totally true,
but that does not heal anything.
Okay? Another person might say, well, worse things happen
to other people, implying you shouldn't let
this bother you that much.
Now, is that a factual statement?
Yeah, I think we can always find somebody who's been
through more than we've been through,
but that is not what God says to do with it.
So we would discourage them from making those kinds of, uh,
comments or even comparisons to themselves
and definitely not to someone else who's hurting.
Uh, some of us were criticized
because we were sad or crying.
Somebody said, well, you're just being too sensitive.
And the thing is, unless they are dramatically
exaggerating their pain, willfully dramatically
exaggerating it, pain is pain, okay?
And if they're feeling sad, they're feeling sad,
and who are we to judge?
Whether they are expressing it too loudly,
I'd say, that's not what I'm called to do.
So we were criticized
and that just puts a layer of condemnation on top of
the criticism, On top of the hurt, rather.
Uh, thirdly, we might, um, find
that when we are sad,
the other person that we're sharing that with says,
you think that's bad?
Let me tell you what happened to me. And they won up us.
Okay? Uh, George
and I, by the way, would both confess, we've done every one
of these things wrong and more often than we'd like
to admit, but once we learned,
it was almost like we caught ourselves a lot of times.
And we catch ourselves doing that, um, pep talks
and, and we can spiritualize pep talks.
We can say, you know, God's on his throne, don't you?
He'll probably make a ministry out
of this pain that you went through.
Now, whether he does or not is up to God,
but that's not his answer to your sadness.
So avoid pep talks.
Uh, sometimes we get pep talks
because we're not comfortable with this person crying.
And then finally, uh, neglect
where nothing is said.
So seeing
that the clock has moved faster than I thought it would, uh,
I know better than to extend unnecessarily.
So what I'm gonna do is just encourage you to
keep practicing.
Not only rejoice for those who rejoice,
but more those who mourn.
Those ought to be lifestyle influences from now on.
And don't miss how powerful they can be with other people
because, 'cause a lot of people are getting pep talks,
spiritual pep talks, rationale
because that's all that some people know to do
and they're trying to help, but it's not very helpful.
Comfort is an issue of the heart, not the rational mind.
When Jesus was moved with compassion,
he didn't preach a sermon,
he offered Kerry wept.
That was very healing for Mary
and Martha, next time,
please hold me accountable for this.
I'm going to show a
video that has to do with
a Jesus who pursues you.
He pursues you with love
and care and support.
Doesn't mean that we have never gone through something
where bad things happen to us.
And we might say, well, where was Jesus?
I'm saying, I don't know, but his word says that
even if it, you still go through some painful things,
he is pursuing you.
And I'll show you an example next week from the scripture
And we'll start with that just as a way of kind
of bringing this, how's Jesus get involved in this with us?
Okay. Questions or thoughts?
So all the recordings, how do we get to them?
Uh, you should have gotten an email with the link
One. You've
Got that. Okay. And so
you just click on that link
and it ought to work if it just
Put the one link? Or is it add?
Uh, we did them for the past two weeks
and this, this one we've got part of it.
Okay. And it's more audible than it is, you know,
it's just looking at that screen right now.
But, um, at least it'll be the audible part of it.
And, uh, I think what I'll do is at least
I'll capture these drawings just so anybody who's looking at
that can tell what we were talking about.
Okay. Alright.
Well thank you all for all of your attention
and participation and, uh, didn't have to twist your arm
to get you to share earlier tonight.
That was good. That's real good. So we'll see you next week.
Okay? You
Bet.